it is nicola sturgeon said today the
last thing she wanted to have to do
to reimpose lockdown measures on
hundreds of thousands of people in
aberdeen
but kobit 19 is spreading out of control
again here people flooding to bars and
restaurants at least partly to blame
unless the situation improves schools
may not reopen
from today people in aberdeen should not
go into each other's
houses we will be introducing
regulations we will publish these later
today
requiring all indoor and outdoor
hospitality in the city
to close by 5 pm today the last thing we
want to do
is reimpose these kinds of restrictions
but this outbreak is reminding us
just how highly infectious covert is
this is also about
doing everything we can to ensure our
children can return to school next week
the scottish first minister knows that
trade-offs have to be made and she's
willing to be explicit about them in the
hope that people follow the rules
but here in westminster the idea of a
nationwide
compromise like closing pubs to open
schools is still being written off by
number 10.
scientists are saying it but politicians
won't instead
they're pointing to local measures to
stop the spread of the virus
we will have to look at this on a
case-by-case basis but the approach is
very much on looking at this at a
localized level
but of course uh we want the message
very close that we want all schools to
be coming back with all pupils in
september
but what if local lockdowns don't work
ministers guarantee that children will
go back to school in september but if
the virus takes hold again
can they deliver the labour leader says
time is running out to prove it
we need to get our children back into
schools that has to be the priority
but the government is running out of
time we've got schools reopening
in september we've got outbreaks of the
infection across the country
and the government's got basically the
months of august
to get a grip on this it's the height of
summer and the virus is already starting
to gather pace again in some uk towns
and cities
with autumn will come the return of
schools colder weather and
more chances for the virus to spread
like it or not that might mean
trade-offs for us all kate mccann sky
news